hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen hier heute zu einem neuen
video ich in letzter zeit irgendwie jede
freie sekunde auf musicali unterwegs bin
ich heiß der laser luca und ich habe
auch schon ein video war so zehn
typische arten von musical user letztes
hoch geladen habe
hab ich mir gedacht ich versuche einfach
mal beim musical ließ nachzustellen
übrigens sorry falls sie dich
verhältnisse hier die ganzheitliche
umschwenken weil er scheint die sonne
dann ist es abregnen da vorne schneiden
sie doch neben dass das hier ist das
erste musical was ich heute versuche
nachzustellen ihr seht schon das bin ich
und ohne ton sieht das auch relativ
bescheuert aus
das war zudem blieb name ist broccoli
heißt es glaube ich habe dazu ein
bisschen rum gespart hat darin den deb
rausgeholt und ich versuche das jetzt
nachzustellen
irgendwie mit der cam in meiner hand ich
meinen viele würden sagen hey luca dass
dein eigenes musical die das ist relativ
die das ganze was das für das ist voll
wie sie das nachzustellen
ich halte es aber eine fette dslr kämen
der hanno sieht dass hier für mich aus
und dieses ding wiegt gefühlte 40 tonnen
also zunächst mal muss ich ganz normal
sind
ok ich muss sie kennen wieder operativ
backen
okay das war relativ simpel
alles gepasst
ambühl sagte massa das nächste musical
über das nachstellen werde ist dieses
hier
ich meine ok immer wenn man musicals
nach macht kommt diese komische jazz
rally challenge aber deswegen versuche
ich das jetzt auch noch zu machen also
er hat hier zu beginn drei bilder von
sicherheits kleines kind das heißt sie
nämlich von mir ist erst mal kurz auf
sodass ist die aufnahme von dem ersten
bild dann haben wir hier auch schon
direkt die zweite aufnahme und das
dritte mal luca als kleinkind das was
ich als nächstes machen muss mich
behindert darstellen reicht das
das hier ist das nächste musical dass
ich versuchen werde nachzustellen ich
kenne die person nicht kennen das lied
nicht ich kann nicht tanzen kann nur gut
werden die kernproben aus meiner höhe
ein paar sekunden später
ich bin ich habe keine ahnung wie ich
das machen soll gar keine frage sie kann
das alles besser als ich aber ich glaube
ehrlich gesagt nicht dass das gut
hingekriegt habe aber wir schauen uns
das mal eine gegenüberstellung an
das nächste musical von einer person die
auf der einen seite von seinen fans sehr
gemocht wird auf der anderen seite von
sehr vielen leuten auch gehasst wird
ich weiß nicht wie du ziemlich jetzt von
dort seit dem musical ist und die finde
ich selber nicht so gut ich finde man
kann so viel mehr machen als einfach
sein handy in die hand zu nehmen und
seinen mund zu bewegen und sich durch
die haare zu fassen aber ich habe
wirklich nichts gegen ihn persönlich
kenne ich halt nicht persönlich und ja
ich glaube es gibt eh schon viel zu viel
hass im internet deswegen muss ich jetzt
auch nicht auf irgendwelchen leuten rum
hat nicht weinen wenn er feiert ist es
cool wenn die fans ist ein ist es cool
dann sind wir alle glücklich aber meiner
von musical ist es nicht aber ich
versuche mal nach zu machen ich muss
wieder die kamera hier in die hand
nehmen vom stativ unter und jetzt mich
irgendwie bewegen wie er dazu also ich
probiere das jetzt mal direkt okay ich
probier's mal einer gegenüberstellung
wir kommen zum nächsten musical i sing
ich liebe singen also es gibt nichts was
ich mir wünschen könnte als zu sehen
jetzt durch hast du singen
ich kann es nicht und ich hasse ich
meine musical lief mit man ja eigentlich
mein halber geschwindigkeit auf und die
app macht ist meine kamera stehen wir
die krise dann irgendwie mal halber
geschwindigkeit auf und spielt sie darin
der wegen doppelter geschwindigkeit ab
so dass das ganze diese scheiß wetter
und in doppelter geschwindigkeit ab so
dass unsere bewegung wie beispielsweise
diese hier dann so aussieht und alle
denken es ist irgendwie kraft aus und es
sieht auch grass aus setzt wegen werde
ich jetzt auch ein halber
geschwindigkeit singe ich habe dafür
extra kopfhörer aufgesetzt und es geht
los meine damen herren halber
geschwindigkeit
das ist war super
letztes musical nicht wie heute
wie wie soll ich das nachstellen mal in
motivation ist am ende
das war es ihr vom video meine damen und
herren ich hoffe ich konnte euch in
irgendeiner form unser halten falls das
schaffen konnte lernende bewertung da
beim musical videos kommen sollen ich
wollte vielleicht auch mal so die
bescheuerten musical ist hier irgendwie
gesehen haben videos zeigen allerdings
macht sein und es hier schon in serie
allerdings wollte ich es vielleicht zu
machen dass ich mir einfach dem musical
ist und gerade wenn ich beispielsweise
auf dem klo sitze oder in der bahn
sitzen oder wo auch immer und wenn ich
denke das ist total bescheuert dann
hatte ich mir runter und kennen das
quasi schon und rädern darauf nicht live
sondern im nachhinein und macht das ein
bisschen einfacher seite davon wenn ihr
noch dran sein schreibt man musical i
und in die kommentare
los